leave it to Nintendo to make a game
relevant after 13 years The Legend of
Zelda the Ocarina of Time 3d right so
I'll say it right now I never actually
played The Legend of Zelda Ocarina of
Time before it was on 3ds because it
came out in the 90s and that was like
the height of console wars what the 90s
was all about at any given time there
were two systems out you had one or the
other you had to choose a side I had
PlayStation and so I always said I was
going to get the 3ds when Ocarina of
Time came out cuz it'd be a good time
for me to play it for the first time so
it came out and I had to shell out the
money put my money where my mouth was
and I got to say this game holds up now
they read that the graphics for the 3d
assets in widescreen now and the
polygons are a lot smoother it doesn't
look outdated like ocarina of time for
the Virtual Console on the Wii it shows
its age graphically for the 3ds so it's
really impressed and the 3d in the game
is really cool too
it's annoying at first cuz you got to
keep it like right there like 1 foot
from your face and I like being a lazy
gamer like I'm hanging back you know
it's kind of at an angle like whatever
I'm just laying down in bed you can't
really do that but you get used to it
pretty quickly and if you want you can
just turn off the 3d but the textures in
this game were nice and round like 3d
should be they weren't like flat pieces
of paper on flat pieces of paper in the
background right onto the game now The
Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time was
really fun to play usually games that
are like 13 years old you play now and
you're like I was fun back then that was
before I had the options I have now but
Ocarina of Time it hooked me I mean it's
The Legend of Zelda I played Twilight
Princess Twilight Princess in Ocarina of
Time play really similar same kind of
sort attacks you don't use the shield to
slam the guy or anything like that
unlike Twilight Princess where they have
you turn into a wolf and in turning the
link in Ocarina of Time you go from
young links to adult link can't be the
back and forth thing figuring out
puzzles and the puzzles in this guy one
important thing from playing ocarina of
time and that is I was a much better
gamer back in today I'm fully convinced
like back in the day I would have
figured out all the puzzles myself for
some odd reason when I was younger I was
just better at connecting A to B I think
it was because games nowadays just kind
of hold your hand and they've made me
dumber
thanks modern games and Twilight
Princess there's a little thing that
showed you like generally speaking where
a heart container piece was now not in
this one but back then the like not
here's your world talk to a guy who's
going to give you a vague ask clue and
then you know get the heart container
piece or find the dungeon or walk
through the wall like there's a scene in
this game I had to walk through the wall
to progress the game usually a game
would let you know that walking through
a wall is now a mechanic of the game
you've never walked through a wall in
this entire game yet so it doesn't tell
you that you know to get through this
room
have to walk through a wall [ __ ] I
felt stupid after I game fact it I hate
using game fact but this game made me
use game back a couple times was like I
said I'm not as smart now and to all you
out there gonna be like cooking for
Jeremy fail whatever dude now as fun as
this game was I knew it was coming
because in every one of these 3d
adventure platformers there's always a
level that's known as the water I hate
water levels I hate them more than like
anything mushrooms water levels this was
water level with a vengence multi Ford
Puzzle water level it's as bad as it
gets not quite as bad as the ice level
and a Link to the Past but it was I
didn't like it now I will say that the
Zelda games in general and this one
specifically it's really light on story
generally speaking there's like a bad
guy you're a good guy you stop bad guys
from doing bad guy things but I wanted
to know more about the characters I
wanted to know more about Ganondorf that
dude's an awesome villain he's like an
iconic villain in the video game world
he's from Garuda Valley that's cool he
screwed Hyrule now I got to stop him
that's really all you know about him
speaking of gerudo valley gerudo valley
is a place in ocarina of time it has the
best song ever it's just one of those
songs you go to that place and you just
stand there and you listen to the song
the annoying things for me is the button
that turns your camera to face where
you're facing is also the button that
targets enemies so rest assured when you
want to do one it'll probably do the
other that annoyed the [ __ ] out of me
almost as much as that stupid little
fairy you have a fairy that flies around
with you and it doesn't shut up you're
doing something you're really throwing
down with a guy and so fairies like hey
I know stop it stop stop it stop it
shut up I hated that fairy and one of
the boss fights the fairies like oh
there's all this energy I can't help you
link I'm sorry I'm like thank you dude
you and me we're pals it come on let's
hang outs go drink some red potions and
kick back so the gameplay is really fun
you're gonna be entertained for days
with this game it's gonna take you an
eon and a half to realize it you're
gonna have to Google the secrets to find
out where everything is when you do
don't worry we've all done it you're
gonna get frustrated you're gonna get
stuck but in the end the game holds up
to today 13 years later if you have a
3ds and you don't have Ocarina of Time
I'm getting so what's your favorite
Zelda game and/or your least favorite
Zelda dungeon comment below let me know
now you can officially look below and
find all the ice and water dungeons in
Zelda games listed below and if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you